Buenos días la ex vicepresidenta del
parlamento europeo Eva kyli está
previsto que comparezca hoy ante el juez
en que va a pedir su inocencia y también
su libertad Aunque su equipo de abogados
ha avanzado que intentará que se
posponga este esta vista con el juez
debido a que hoy hay una huelga en
Bélgica de funcionarios y policías sobre
el dinero encontrado en el domicilio de
Kylie su defensa ha explicado que Kylie
desconocía que hubiese este dinero en su
hogar y que los contactos que siempre
había mantenido Kylie con
Qatar siempre habían sido reuniones
oficiales en el marco de las relaciones
que mantiene la Unión Europea con los
países del Golfo mientras Las
investigaciones prosiguen la policía ha
hecho público hoy unas informaciones en
Que en total se han encontrado 1,5
millones de euros en total desde que se
produjeron los registros mientras el
parlamento europeo está investigando
las legislaciones que se han producido
en el marco de esta investigación por
ejemplo un acuerdo recientemente
aprobado entre
Qatar y también La Unión europe